non comme tout va bien on va faire une
interview au cauchemar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gal elmaleh le pire des accidents
conjugaux vous faire surprendre par
votre femme avec votre maîtresse
n'importe quoi surprendre votre flamme
avec votre meilleure amie ou surprendre
votre femme et votre maîtresse ensemble
c'est sûr prendre ma femme avec mon
meilleur ami ouais c'est ça sert ips ben
oui c'est oui parce que j'en perds deux
d'un coup
elle n'en dira pas le nom du meilleur
ami de la femme de gad elmaleh on dira
juste ça
la magie en
cette soumission à réputé pour sa
discrétion exactement donc on donne pas
les noms ne veulent que des indices
voilà alors le pire cadeau qu'on puisse
vous faire une perceuse sans fil un
abonnement un club de gym huit jours de
vacances avec vincent perrot
un abonnement avait un club de gym parce
que déjà avec un seul abonnement je vous
croise dans les vestiaires ouais c'est
vrai alors avec deux je crains tu perds
[Applaudissements]
la pire situation au quotidien avoir un
pétard mais pas de feu une carte bleue
mais pas le code une fille super mais
pas de préservatif une si super mais pas
le fond quoi
votre cuir désillusion gad elmaleh ça
serait d'apprendre qu'il y a quelqu'un
dans casimir
que thierry la fronde avait une
chaussette dans son collant ou que
goldorak et doublé pour les cascades que
goldorak et doublement les cascades
parce que ça c'est
dégueulasse le pire ce serait
d'apprendre que dieu n'existe pas ou
qu'il existe mais que ce n'est pas le
vôtre
c'est que c'est que c'est que dieu
n'existe pas parce que je pense pas que
le dieu que quand quelle je crois parce
que je crois en dieu soit que le mien
non mais c'est qu'il n'existe pas passé
avec le nombre de mecs qui se sont fait
sauter en l'air et quand tu es des gens
pour dieu ouais c'est pas très sympa
s'il existera le pire c'est de grandir
salle de vivre seul ou de mourir seul de
mourir seul parce que je l' ai déjà vécu
et je dois dire que c'est assez dur
ouais vraiment ouais parce que de
grandir seul je les fait vivre seul je
l' ai déjà vécu mourir seul plus jamais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu